überall in der republik erstrahlt die
weihnachtsbeleuchtung nicht aber im
nordrhein-westfälischen neuss in den
stadtteilen reuschenberg und husten
in der finkenstraße hat die stadt die
aufhängungen an den laternen vor dem
ersten advent ganz einfach abmontiert in
der kreuzstraße hatten die bürger die
beleuchtung schon aufgehängt mussten sie
dann aber auch städtischen befehl wieder
abnehmen schöne bescherung die bürger
sind stinksauer und hat verträge mit uns
veranstalten finde ich eine sauerei hoch
drei das mit druck die leute gezwungen
wurden die weihnachtsbeleuchtung wieder
abzunehmen das geht einfach nicht es ist
unmöglich alles bleibt an den einwohnern
hängen dass sie selber schmücken müssen
und ich finde es eine frechheit von der
stadt dass sie sich das rausgenommen
haben die die sachen abzubauen
seit 14 jahren hängt an den
straßenlaternen die festliche
weihnachtsbeleuchtung eigentlich denn
dieses jahr musste alles zurück in den
keller
dabei kostet der ganze spaß die stadt
keinen cent die deko haben die bürger
selber gekauft der strom kommt von den
hausanschlüssen genau das heißt es bei
der stadt neuss sei viel zu gefährlich
unsinn meint roland wierig vom örtlichen
weihnachts komitee denn er hat eine
gruppe von experten am start
wir sind hier drei elektrofachkräfte und
einer von denen ist sogar meister und
alles was welche installiert haben
spricht nach unserer auffassung aller
karten regeln der technik sprich als dvd
isoliert es sind spezielle kabel gelegt
vor dass der fachleute am werk sind
interessiert im neusser rathaus niemand
auch nicht dass die beleuchtung
technisch in einem top zustand ist die
stadt bleibt dabei ja weil ich
eigentlich zu einem sicheren betrieb von
laternen keine alternative gibt wir
müssen die dinge abhängen weil wir nicht
wissen was auf der anderen seite für
eine elektrische installation
vorgenommen ist können wir nicht sehen
wir können den kein haus rein gehen 14
jahre hat alles einwandfrei funktioniert
und geleuchtet plötzlich kommt die stadt
mit dieser bescherung um die ecke
auf einmal leises buch warf die
weihnachtsbeleuchtung muss wieder
abgehangen werden wir waren natürlich
alle nz sind sehr enttäuscht und halten
die aktion eben da sonst das
verunmöglicht wurde seitens der stadt
für eine bürger und freunde schaltung
und das sehr ärgerlich weil das sind so
kleine strecken wo sich wo sich daran
stören die sollten besser andere dinge
in angriff nehmen damit es hier im
nächsten jahr an weihnachten nicht
wieder so trostlos aussieht will die
stadt jede laterne mit einer eigenen
steckdose ausrüsten so soll die
weihnachtsbeleuchtung sicher mit strom
versorgt werden
ach ja zahlen sollen das ganze natürlich
die anwohner in diesem sinne frohes fest